choosing the right health insurance plan
is not only important it's personal now
is the time to make changes and Select
Health the sponsors of this next segment
are here to help let's welcome to the
show Linda baronishin who is a senior
account manager for individual and small
employer products at Select Health
welcome to the show thank you it's happy
to be here it's great to have you here
let's talk about it what are the dates
for open enrollment okay so the dates
are important for nevadans the Open
Enrollment season started November 1st
okay and it goes all the way through
January 15th now if someone wants to
start coverage on the first of the year
they need to take action sooner than
later they do so their applications need
to be completed and submitted no later
than December 31st okay so get it done
by the end of the year get it done by
the end of the year if you don't if you
enroll between January 1st and the 15th
you're going to have a February first
effective date okay that's that's good
that's good information to have and when
it comes to information your website has
everything but you also have
Representatives on the standby on the
phone to answer questions absolutely we
sure do we are ready to take your call
all and some of the new things that we
have coming for 2023 are pretty exciting
to us we are actually in 2023 starting
uh in January all of our individual and
family plans will now have a new benefit
that will cover the cost of chronic
condition medications I had to make sure
I say that right and that's all at zero
cost to the member that is huge
absolutely that's big news it is big
news we're also launching a diabetes
support plan although you don't have to
be a diabetic to enroll in this plan but
what it's going to offer is it's going
to offer zero and low-cost co-pays on
medications on classes on doctor visits
and supplies there's one thing Austin
too you have to do I want to touch on is
your Wellness Rewards program tell us
more about that because that's pretty
cool that is a very cool program it is
pretty it's basically rewarding members
for living a healthier life so it can be
something as easy as having a gym
membership walking 7 000 steps a day for
20 days in a month I think that's right
and you can get up to 240 dollars
reimbursed per individual and 580 per
family so you're rewarding people for
staying healthy absolutely and for
watching out for their health which is
great so the cost of living the cost of
everything has gone up yes but you guys
have ways to save money tell us more
about that we do so the first thing
people want to do before they even start
to figure out you know what they're
going to do for next year is go to the
Nevada Health Link website and see if
you qualify for a government subsidy
because even if you didn't qualify last
year you might qualify this year plans
change everything changes from year to
year but Select Health will offer like
we said so these rewards programs but we
also offer discounts on services that
typically aren't covered under an
insurance plan such as Lasik acupuncture
I gotta wrap things up here because you
have so much great information and we
have the website and your agents are on
standby to answer all their questions
sales reps are ready to take your calls
thank you so much we appreciate it and
thank you for sponsoring this segment
for more information call
1-855-442-0220 or visit
selectthealth.org in Las Vegas now we'll
be right back